THE LAST COUPLE.
I'M SURE HE LIKED THE RESULT.
>> Harnaryan: A CROSS-ICE FOR
PODKOLZIN.
BACK TO  STARTING TO HEAT UP.
>> Harnaryan: CANUCKSSBREAKAWAY.
AND DEMKO UP TO THE TASK ONN.
CANUCKS LINE APPLYING PRESSURE.
PODKOLZIN SHOOTS.
PODKOLZIN THERE.
FLAMES TAKE OVER.
IT'S FLIPPED OUT BYSCORES!
[ Horn ]BY.
HE LETS IT RIP ON A NICE FEED
FROM HUGHES.
THE CANUCKS ARE ON THE BOARD ON.
LEFT IT THERE FOR TKACHUK WHO
WAS TAKEN DOWN. GOAL FOR
THE VANCOUVER CANUCKS HAS THEM .
MILLER WITH THE SHOT.
PERFECT POSITION
[ Horn ]
>> Harnaryan: JUST LIKE THAT,
THE CANUCKS LEAD 3-NOTHING.AGAI
OVER THE BLOCKER ON IT.
COULDN'T GET A SHOT OFF.
HE
RIGHT ARM.
I THINK HE GOT THE PADDLE DOWN
ON THAT IN
AND IT'S RASMUS ANDERSSON WHO --
THIS LOOKS LIKE IT'S A
WOW.
COMES IN NICE ANDE TONIGHT AS
LINDHOLM DRIVIMANGIAPANE.
CENTRING PASS.
DEMKO THERIGHT.
TANNER PEARSON SHOOTS.
REBOUND.
AND CONOR GARLAND SCORES TO
PETTERSSON.
LETS IT GO.
THERE'S THAT BIGSCORES!
[ Horn ]
7-NOTHING OUT OF THE
GARY
FLAMES.
>> Greg: LOOK OUT AGAIN.
>> Harnaryan: HERE COMES MATTHEW
HIGHMOLAMMIKKO.
HERE'S TYLER MOTTE.
SHOOTS!
DID THAT
MANGIAPANE.
AND A BEAUTIFUL BACKHAND DEKE TO
GET THEHE
WITH IN THE PAST SORTING OUT THE